macht uns jetzt das nächste virus den
unbeschwerten sommer kaputt kommt jetzt
etwa der affen pocken lockdown immer
mehr fälle von den affen pocken werden
bekannt allein in berlin sind es schon
drei menschen doch was ist das
eigentlich für eine krankheit die sachen
packen
die affen brocken kommen nun auch
vermehrt nach deutschland bisher bekannt
insgesamt mehr als 100 fälle in 12
ländern und das innerhalb von nur zwei
wochen bei den affen pocken handle es
sich um eine klassische schmierinfektion
übertragung durch körperflüssigkeit aber
auch das gemeinsame nutzen von
bettwäsche oder das teilen von kleidung
häufig wechselnde sexualpartner und
ungeschützter sex sind weitere
risikofaktoren die symptome fieber kopf-
und muskelschmerzen und ein ausschlag
der oft im gesicht blicken scheint sich
zu bestätigen was die genomsequenzierung
gebracht hat dass es sowohl um eine
variante handelt die auch einen milden
verlauf zeitig sicherheitshalber wurde
ich glaube ich auch ein medikament
bestellt das für die kranken helfen kann
aber im moment wird es wohl nicht
benötigt in spanien könnte die gateway
das sogenannte maspalomas festival auf
gran canaria zum infektions hotspot
geworden sein hier feierten vom 5 mai
bis 15 bei 80.000 menschen die
belgischen behörden glauben dass ein
fetisch festival in antwerpen zum
superstar geworden sein könnte daher
gilt jetzt wer infiziert ist muss 21
tage in quarantäne
reiserückkehrern wird geraten bei
ungewöhnlichen hautausschlägen und
vorzüglich einen arzt aufzusuchen
seit anfang mai wurden in mehreren
europäischen und nordamerikanischen
ländern dutzende verdachtsfälle und
bestätigte infektion mit affen poppen
gemeldet etwa in kanada frankreich den
usa und großbritannien die zahl in
spanien nachgewiesener fälle ist derweil
laut medienberichten auf über 30
gestiegen
anstecken kann sich jeder daher
befürchtet man in expertenkreisen dass
die infektion in den sommermonaten
zunehmen werden
ja und über diese affen pocken wollen
wir jetzt auch noch sprechen mit unserem
reporter peter wilke der bei dem doktor
heiko jessen ist dem arzt der jetzt
gleich zwei patienten hier in berlin mit
diesen affen pocken bereits behandelt
hat ja peta wie ist denn da die lage
jetzt
lackierer wir sind eben hier in der
praxis von doktor jessen wo eben zwei
patienten zwei der infizierten insgesamt
in berlin mit bisher drei schon länger
patienten sind uns jetzt auch behandelt
werden und darüber können wir mit dr
jessen sprechender das eben
diagnostiziert hat herr jessen erste
wichtigste frage wie geht es den beiden
es geht beiden inzwischen ganz gut muss
man sagen die sind zu hause sind
isoliert und sind ja beruhigt sie waren
natürlich sehr aufgeregt der erste
identifizierte patient der nicht als
erster herbei wir nennen sie mal den
55-jährigen 30 jährigen der 55 jährige
war am freitagmorgen zu mir gekommen
da hatte ich den verdacht und hab dann
die entsprechenden proben an das robert
koch institut geschickt wir arbeiten
sehr gut zusammen mit herrn professor
andreas nitsche da es auch für die
pocken in deutschland verantwortlich am
robert koch institut und er hat neben
dem bundeswehr institut in münchen die
er den ersten fall untersucht haben hat
er immer ein spezielles pocken labor und
hat dann dort schon am freitagabend das
positive ergebnis festgestellt und uns
mitgeteilt der nächste patient der
sollte eigentlich auch am freitagmorgen
kaum kam nicht dann habe ich ihn mit ein
bisschen druck in am freitag eingestellt
habe auch darum gebeten dass es robert
koch labor offen und arbeitsfähig bleibt
und habe dann selber die proben haben am
samstagmittag wir haben keine kuriere
gerät per motorrad hingebracht ins
hochsicherheitslabor und bekam dann am
samstagabend das positive ergebnis des
zweiten patienten was sind das für so
was sind das für symptome die die beiden
gezeigt haben dass sie ihm zu diesem
verdacht gekommen sei also wer also im
wesentlichen die
form der ausschläge die schon pocken
ähnlich aussehen wir sind ja sehr
erfahren und auch sehr spezialisiert auf
infektionskrankheit auch sexuell
übertragene krankheiten das was manchmal
ähnlich aussehen kann ist eine
herpesinfektion
oder auch eine syphilis infektion und
dieser art typisch aus sie hatten eine
andere band und dieser erste der
55-jährige hatte eben allgemein symptome
die wanten wir sind schon vorbei als er
hier ankam nämlich leichtes fieber
kopfschmerzen gliederschmerzen
spezifische
infektions symptome und dann zeigte er
die beiden pocken sage ich mal eine war
eine schambein gegend also oberhalb des
penis und einer am unterschenkel und die
waren beide trocken schon anfangs sind
die feucht aber wandern trocken also der
krater ist feucht das heißt es war schon
ein paar tage alt wir haben dann mit
einem hubschrauber im robert koch ein
stück von der kruste also von mir von
dem brand lucias vorstellen wie so ein
ganz kleiner vulkan ganz winzig also ein
stück russe abgekratzt und dann ans
robert koch geschickt und da wurde die
pcr gemacht heute war es ja jeder was
eine pcr ist durch kurven und die war
wie gesagt positiv diesen milden verlauf
erkläre ich so was natürlich nur
hypothetisch darauf dass aufgrund das
alter dieses mannes hat er damals noch
eine der letzten brocken schutzimpfung
bekommt denn die wurden ja in
westdeutschland 76 77 eingestellten
ostdeutschland ende der siebziger
das hat ihm offensichtlich nicht vor der
infektion geschützt wir glauben dass wir
die alten so wie ich die zweimal geimpft
sind dann nicht mehr gefährdet sind
deswegen bin ich eigentlich auch gut
geeignet die zu betreuen wenn denn
welche kommen
aber der verlauf war meldet dann an
anders bei dem 30-jährigen der war schon
richtig krank der war auch zuerst
fieber kopfschmerz ging nicht gut und
dann kam die ausschläge nach und nach
und auch in ital analbereich waren
pocken und ihr teilweise waren die wir
sagen konstruieren das heißt die pocken
flossen so zusammen das richtige risse
entstanden und das war sehr schmerzhaft
also für ihn war das schlimmste da ich
die schmerzen die wir mit starken
schmerzmitteln an haben lindern können
wir haben versucht an die virale
substanzen zu bekommen es gibt einen
zugelassen das medikament gegen pocken
das heißt box also tee oder paul otto
doppel telefon ist aber noch nicht im
großhandel angekommen es ist sie muss
jetzt nicht verfügbar ich hoffe das
kommt diese woche das ist so viel ich
was im januar von der iaea also der
europäischen arzneimittelbehörde
zugelassen worden es gibt auch impfungen
moderne anders als die anderen die sind
und deutlich weniger nebenwirkungen
damals gab es ja vor allem den kindern
sogar hirnhautentzündungen ende her
richtig gehirnentzündung und die wandern
behindert anschließen und es war eine
zwangsimpfung es war ziemlich brutal
weil die pocken gab es nicht mehr und
die impfpflicht war noch da dann wurde
sie abgeschafft der neue impfstoff soll
nicht mehr so sein es gibt keine
deutschland gibt in england welchen sich
weist und ich hoffe dass das
gesundheitsministerium so schnell wie
möglich im stoff besorgt wir brauchen
den impfstoff aber nicht für die
allgemeinbevölkerung sage ich mal das
alles nur einschätzung es gibt keine
regeln bisher sondern für menschen die
kontakt hatten mit diesen infizierten
und vielleicht für hoch exponierte also
meine pink singles beiderlei geschlechts
die eine hohe frequenz den
sexualkontakten haben wissen sie denn
schon wo sich die beiden mutmaßlich
angesteckt haben das weiß ich einer hat
sich in einem club in berlin angesteckt
und dem wochenende 6 7 after my der 55
jährige und der jüngere war auf einer
party in cannes canaria diese ob die
nennen es auch csd party es um auf
sexpartys dabei so viele veranstaltungen
er sei da gewesen vom 7 bis zum 10 und
er selber geht auch ganz sicher davon
aus dass er sich dort angesteckt hat bei
beiden kamen die symptome eine woche
später
literatur ist die sogenannte
inkubationszeit 5 bis 20 tage beiden
hier waren es genau eine woche alles
klar vielen dank herr jessen wir haben
es gehört einer der beiden infizierten
war eben tage zuvor gran canaria bei
einem dieser festivals und er jessen hat
uns im vorgespräch auch schon gesagt
dass beide erstmal häusliche quarantäne
geschickt wurden weil sie dort muss man
es nicht besser aufgehoben sind als in
einem krankenhaus denn in einem
krankenhaus sind ja auch viele andere
viren manchmal im fluss und deswegen
glaubte er dass sie dort erst mal besser
aufgehoben sind für die isolation
peter wilke ganz herzlichen dank und
auch herrn herrn doktor jessen über die
schilderungen dieser fälle die er in
berlin behandelt hat danke